so I understand from reading your bio
that you were one of the youngest people
on the crew at PBS yeah in the day for
someone in a similar situation they're
just starting out how would they conduct
themselves how would they manage other
people's expectations and also other
people's egos you know there's gonna be
older people that may resist them or
feel threatened yeah well I started I
got out of college 25 years ago and I
was really lucky to find a television
show called the 90s which was a which
was a documentary series that was based
out of WTTW in Chicago but it was a
national television show so it had a
very big audience and I was lucky to get
in on the ground floor there there were
only about gosh there only about three
or four other people making that show
when I said when I started and so I was
22 and this was a really important
moment within documentary filmmaking
because hi-8 cameras had just come out
then and hi-8 cameras the quality of
that format was much better than VHS
format like there had been like
camcorders that were shot VHS they've
been around for a while but the quality
of those was really pretty low but high
eight was was an affordable and really
high quality format and that's kind of
when I started and so a month or two
after starting at that show I bought my
own high eight camera and so you know
ten years earlier even five years
earlier in order to start shooting for
PBS you'd have to have a lot of
experience you might have to be in a
union you know you'd have to be older
quite frankly and I started shooting for
that show when I was 22 and so I would
go out and shoot something on a Monday
and Saturday night it was on PBS and
that that's pretty on you
that was um I think nowadays maybe that
doesn't seem so strange because so many
people have cameras and access to
distribution is different than it was
and it was then but but to be on one of
the three or four networks four or five
networks at the time and to be that
young I was I was really pretty
fortunate and I think for me I was just
lucky I was working with people who I
liked and and they gave me a chance to
you know to take a swing and I just
remember really at the time remember
thinking you know this is an amazing
opportunity I mean I really I mean I
literally for a couple of years I had
that camera in my hand almost anywhere I
went I mean I carried my camera with me
all the time
and I saw something that was interesting
or someone I wanted to interview I had
my camera with me and I would start
shooting so I think that you know
knowing knowing what you want to do and
having a love for this in my case its
documentary films you know knowing that
is step one and then step two is just
find a good group of people to get in
with early do it with your friends it's
it's it's really you know there's
there's there's there's two types of
people that I've met who really want to
do well in the film business there's
people who want like the fame and
fortune they usually don't do that well
there's there's the other group which is
the group that just really loves movies
and loves telling stories and loves the
collaboration of doing this with people
that you like doing that with your
friends those are the people that that
tend to really do well you know because
that they love it for the right reasons
so what would you say to let's say a 22
year old man or woman who's new in the
industry and and wants to do well I mean
without sounding too jaded not
everybody's a mentor in an environment
and sometimes you're in work
environments that aren't that
collaborative right but you still need
the job you still want the experience
it's
great on the resume how does someone
survive I think for 22 year old kids who
are starting out or even younger who are
starting out and want to get in to the
film and television business number one
is is know what you love like if you
love musicals watch as many musicals as
you can start to put the names to the
work start to really figure out I mean
there are people behind those behind
that work figure out who they are find
them or find people who know them or
work with that more or people who are
doing work like them okay
musicals is a fairly specific genre but
maybe it's animation maybe it's
television news
maybe it's documentaries maybe it's big
Hollywood productions whatever that is
pinpoint who your heroes are and if
you're not able to work with them you
should be able to find work that's like
the work that they do that's number one
number two this is a very important rule
don't work with a jerk if you're working
with someone and they're lame bail on
them like I quit goodbye and turn and
walk out the door because life is too
short to work for someone who's mean or
you know really impatient is not willing
to share their knowledge maybe they're
insecure in their own abilities and they
don't they're too busy trying to figure
out how they want to get ahead to stop
and help somebody else try to get ahead
so I mean you know what when you see it
you know but at the same time if you
find someone whose work you admire and
they're willing to sort of help you and
mentor you do whatever you can to keep
that job or to keep that position my my
first year at PBS I was an intern I mean
I had already graduated from college I
was an intern for the first six
months and I they were not able to pay
me but I loved working there so I got a
job at night and worked in a restaurant
five nights a week and then during the
day I work for PBS and you know
eventually they hired me and they knew
they weren't gonna get rid of me so they
had to hire me and then I was there
about three years and then I went to
grad school and went one to the American
Film Institute and studied there as well
it's got to keep at it don't let one
person you know don't let one bad
experience one bad project one bad
anything slowed you down because you
know the film business is unlike is
unlike most careers if you start out
when you're 20 you could have easily and
you can have a fifty to sixty year
career it's a long time you know
filmmakers oftentimes I think are like
like a good bottle of wine I mean they
they get better with age
compare that to say like a professional
athlete most of them are wrapped you
know they're washed up with that career
before they hit 30 they may go on to do
other great things but that's a really
short career filmmaking and storytelling
more and more is is is a it's a real
it's a real professional pursuit the
world needs great storytellers and it's
something that you can do almost until
the day you drop so it's it's you have
to be patient just hang in there
you